Chuck yeah Mercury is in retrograde
[Laughter]
[Music]
again but unless you're like a time
traveler from a pre-scientific era right
which is most of human history yes you
got nothing to worry about okay I'm just
saying I don't have to worry that
everything nothing's going to work now
Mercury's in retrograde nothing in my
life is going to work before we
understood the solar system right Earth
was deeply believed to be in the center
of all motion right the universe was
just as it appeared to us no one thought
to question it that it may be deceiving
us simply because of our actual position
among the planets stars and galaxies
okay so if you're in the middle of
everything everything goes around you
woo
yes and there was seven
objects that moved around us that
appeared to move against the background
stars and those seven objects were
Mercury Venus Mars Jupiter Saturn the
Sun and the Moon right those are the
only seven known objects that moved
around the earth and we thought that was
all because of
us look at this why why wouldn't you
think that that's true you're sitting
here on it is going around you it rises
and our vocabulary today still captures
that fact that boy thinks the the sun
rises and sets in you girl right right
right and we keep that vocabulary
because it's easy it's better than
saying Earth has just rotated such that
our sight line to the sun has it emerge
Over the Horizon that's nobody says that
we just say the sun just rose right
sensibly and simply but if you go back
into that time and you're watching it
and you think everything's going around
you right and then you see Mercury
moving like everybody else and then it
slows down stops and then goes
backwards that's some freaky stuff that
is freaky that's freaky stuff yeah and
for a period of time it moves backwards
against the background stars and then it
slows down stops and then goes forward
again and oh now if you believe the
universe had control over you then these
are problem times yes this you'd worry
about this I got to change my life and
so we needed the methods and tools of
science to figure this out right and how
did that go well once you realize that
Earth is just one among all the other
objects going around the Sun okay once
you realize that think about it if
something is closer to the Sun than you
are right and by the way those objects
move faster than you do okay so which
planet would move the fastest uh the one
that's closest to the Sun which is
Mercury Mercury right Mercury and Roman
God my boy had wings on his feet oh
that's right fast yeah they knew that's
right knew the deal he knew the deal so
watch so there we are watching Mercury
go around we're going around the sun too
but Mercury is doing it faster so it
it's moving like from the left to the
right in our field of view but then it
has has to go around the backside of the
sun right how's it going to do that it's
going to switch directions in the sky
right he and then continue as it had
before so depending on the sight line
between Earth and Mercury it'll appear
to go backwards but nothing is going
backwards let's say you're at a car race
all right you're at NASCAR and there
they are driving around when they're
near you they're going left to right
right when they go around to the other
side of the track they're going from
right to left the cars are all in
retrograde so no one is freaking out
when you see the car right on the other
side of the track going right to the
left that's retrograde and that's it
that's what people are saying about
Mercury believe that somehow that has a
bad effect on you what we call the inner
planets which is Mercury and Venus they
go through this sort of retrograde more
frequently than outer planets right okay
outer ones would be Mars Jupiter Saturn
and the like given the configuration of
this sort of racetrack around the Sun
everybody will spend some time going
into retrograde to everybody else so
relative to one another everybody goes
into ret somebody's going into
retrograde somebody doing somebody's
doing it and even the outer planets to
us will'll see them go into retrograde
cuz we're the ones going around the Sun
and switching Direction there you go and
so it look like to us our line of sight
to them sends them going backwards you
know I'm picking up a theme here what's
that uh don't say something is in
retrograde and that's why you life is
bad cuz it makes sound
stupid plus there's always somebody in
everybody's always in retrograde you
ain't
special so basically everybody spends
some time doing retrograde but nothing
is actually moving backwards and the
fact that there's a word for it
retrograde sounds serious sounds serious
it sounds like oh my gosh we need not
only a word for that we need to worry
about it right right yeah but if you
would known from the beginning that
Earth was not the center of all motion
this becomes a trivial explanation of
all objects moving in the same direction
around the Sun just some moving at
different speeds than others so it's not
all about you Earth it's not about you
so think about in the future we might
have colonies on Mars yes if we're on
Mars then Earth is an inner planet right
so you on Mars you're going to see Earth
do some retrograde oh man I lost my keys
Earth is in
retrograd you lost your Martian keys I
lost my Martian keys so it's just a
matter of your point of view
on what is a very normal regular system
of motion mhm planets orbiting a host
star okay so I get all that yeah here's
what I need to know yes what does that
mean for
Sagittarius cuz I'm a sad okay if it
goes in
retrograde while it's in s Sagittarius
right oh my gosh that means
nothing no the thing is mercury goes
through retrograde you know a couple of
times a year Mercury's orbit around the
Sun is like 88 days okay so this happens
a few times a year you know with some
frequency
that generally something's going to go
wrong this year for you exactly okay are
you kidding me
we're talking about me here now if if
mgy doesn't happen to be in retrograde
it just something went wrong with you
right if you have something to blame it
on then you do then you do yeah right
that's what it comes down to that's what
it comes down to and even if you know
today it's not moving backwards but you
want to sort of pay respects to a
pre-scientific
era do so knowing that they had no idea
what they were looking at right and that
infused an
entire
system
of control over your life because it
feels good well it's it's it relieves
you of your accountability right you
don't have any responsibility blame the
universe yeah I can just blame the Stars
stupid
Mercury so I got to end with a quote
from The
Bard Julius Caesar Julius Caesar the
fault dear Brutus uhhuh lies not in the
stars but in ourselves ooh Oh I thought
it was Brutus you traitorous son of a
that that comes oh that comes later that
comes later
okay so there you have it Chu oh that's
great just putting that in line that's
awesome all right once again this has
been Star Talk Neil degrass Tyson my
co-host Chuck nice as always keep
looking
[Music]
up